Flow genome project.
What we've discovered when people want
more flow in their lives,
the number one thing we can tell them is
that there is a flow cycle.
So the old idea about flow was that it
was a binary,
it was like a light switch.
You were in the zone or you were out his
own.
What we now know is that flow is a four
part cycle and you have to move through
all four parts of these cycle of the
cycle before you can return to the flow
state itself,
the neurobiology,
that flow side.
When the actual research came out of her
Benson's work at Harvard,
he kind of laid the foundation for it.
But what we've discovered is that the
front end of the flow state,
there's a struggle phase.
This is a loading phase.
You are loading then overloading the
brain with information for a baseball
player.
This is learning to swing a bat and a
ball for a writer planning a new book.
This is when you're doing interviews,
this is when you're reading,
it's when you're diagramming structure
and things like that.
It's very unpleasant as a general rule.
So even the flow may be the most
desirable and pleasant stayed on earth.
The actual flow cycle itself starts with
a very unpleasant state known as
struggle from struggle.
You move into a release.
This literally means you want to take
your mind off the problem.
So what happens in flow is we are
trading conscious processing,
which is slow,
has very limited Ram,
right?
The working memory can only hold about
four items at once and it's very energy
inefficient for subconscious processing,
which is extremely fast.
It's very energy efficient and has
pretty much endless ram.
So to do that you have to move from
struggle.
You'll have to let stop thinking about
what you were trying to think about.
Basically,
you take your mind off the problem,
you go for long walks.
Gardening works very well.
Building models works very,
very well.
Albert Einstein famously used to row a
boat in the middle of Lake Geneva and
stare at the clouds,
right?
Once you can take your mind off the
problem and it won't.
By the way,
one of the only things that you can't do
to move through release is watched
television.
It actually changes your brain waves in
a way that will block flow.
But once you move from release,
there's a,
actually underneath the surface neuro,
biologically there's a global release of
nitric oxide,
which is a gas is signaling molecule.
It's found everywhere in the body.
This flushes all the stress hormones out
of your system and replaces them with
kind of feel good performance.
Nancy neurochemicals like dopamine and
Serotonin and endorphins which underpin
the flow state as well.
You're in the flow state itself.
This is the third stage and the struggle
and on the back end of the flow state
there is actually a recovery phase and
this is really,
really,
really critical.
So you go from this amazing high of flow
to a very deep low that shows up in
recovery.
A lot of this is that all those feelgood
neurochemicals that drained out of your
system,
it takes certain vitamins and minerals
and sunlight and things like that to
rebuild them.
So the recovery phase on the back end of
the flow state is actually very,
very unpleasant as well.
And if you really want to hack flow,
you need to learn how to struggle better
and you need how to learn how to
recover.
And one of the most important things in
recovery is you have to,
you need some emotional fortitude,
some grit.
You have to basically hold onto your
emotions,
not get stressed out at the fact that
you no longer feel like superman.
And the main reason,
what two reasons for this is one,
if you get too stressed out and feeling
low,
you're going to start producing
cortisol.
Little bit is fine.
Too much of it blocks the accelerated
learning that comes with flow.
So you will actually,
you'll get the short term benefit of the
flow state itself,
but you won't get the longterm benefit,
the accelerated learning that you get in
flow.
The other problem is if you have to move
from recovery back into struggle and
you're bummed out at no longer being in
flow during the recovery phase,
it's very hard to get up for the
difficult place of struggle that
follows.